nous trouvons au pied de la cathédrale
sainte croix face nord nous avons eu la
chance de découvrir cette cathédrale
ainsi que la crypte saint-avit avec 15
autres visiteurs alors là je me trouve
avec geneviève notre guide du jour qui
nous a raconté l'histoire de ces lieux
je vous laisse découvrir
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'espère que personne n'a le vertige
parce que nous nous devrons nous ne
revenons jamais en arrière nous moutons
côté sue et nous descendons côté noble
mieux vaut ne pas avoir le vertige donc
pour se rendre en haut de la cathédrale
gothique d'orléans
mais d'abord passage par l'intérieur
décoré par les armoiries des compagnons
d'armes de jeanne d'arc
la pucelle d'orléans avait participé à
une messe au sein de cette cathédrale en
1429 en suisse débute la montée de plus
de 200 marches et là une vue panoramique
sur la ville
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses puisque
moi je ne suis pas orléanais
contrairement majorité des gens qui soit
aussi
moi je viens de tout donc je ne
connaissais tu dis donc je découvre
toute l'histoire de la ville d'orléans
mais extrêmement intéressante et surtout
très riche je ne suis pas sûr que tous
les orléanais connaissait la richesse de
leur histoire parce qu'en fait était une
ville essentielle dans notre royaume de
france vient à paris enfin la descente
vers la crypte sous la terre cette
église en sous-sol servait de refuge aux
premiers chrétiens gaulois lieu de
recueillement
cette crypte découverte au 19e siècle et
pourtant bien plus anciennes elles
abritaient les reliques de saint-avit
mort en l'an 530 et les orléanais eux
aussi découvre l'histoire de leur ville
il découvre des endroits qu'ils ne
connaissent pas et souvent par exemple à
la crypte de saint-avit il passe devant
en voiture mais ils ne voient pas la
petite porte
et donc il est assez là et aujourd'hui
ils sont contents et des fois ils se
disent dont 20 à venir avec les petits
enfants avec des amis et son nationale
vraiment satisfait à la cathédrale
sainte croix la crypte saint-avit deux
monuments de témoins de l'histoire de
france
nous sommes de retour avec geneviève
notre guide du jour
geneviève pourquoi avoir choisi ce
parcours d'orléans vue do samba et bien
cela permet aux visiteurs de découvrir
leur ville du haut de la cathédrale et
du haut de la cathédrale et bien on voit
de nombreux édifices notamment des
églises et aussi des édifices
industriels par exemple comme la
centrale nucléaire de servir en 2e et
puis après après avoir bu orient d'en
haut
eh bien on descend sous terre dans la
cuve de saint-avit ou là on se retrouve
plus ou moins moyen âge et la cathédrale
sainte croix fait face à la rue jeanne
d'arc
qu'est ce qui rattache jeanne d'arc à
cette cathédrale à l'aube le jeûne d'arc
à prier dans le choeur de la cathédrale
de 8 mai 1429 après avoir délivré
ordures et donc au milieu du xixème
siècle la rue qui est perpendiculaire la
cathédrale qu'on appelle d'argentât et
donc percée et on lui donne le nom de
notre héroïne inquiète d'ailleurs très
présents dans toute la ville